tim is wearing sensors recording from my
ear brain activity and we're recording
heart rate and recording movement from
the chest we're streaming this to the
cloud where we're translating this into
measures of my relaxation level my heart
rate we can get heart rate variability
we can get variety of states that are
related to the types of signals that I
can get here from this in the air sensor
and from my heart rate monitor and all
that happen in the cloud and coming back
to my mobile device so we've got our EEG
our ECG our heart activity my relaxation
score actigraph e so if I move around a
little bit it's gonna go up it gets all
red and I'll be still and then my heart
rate and so we can take all of this and
we can do something kind of cool like
this because all my data is going
through neuro scale hey Alexa ask neuro
scale for my current relaxation level
your current relaxation level is 20%
you're pretty pumped up if you feel like
relaxing a bit we could do some
meditation exercises together and that's
an example of how we can integrate
something like Amazon Alexa through the
neuro scale platform connect that to my
brain and my heart my body do something
useful like asking Alexa what's my state
how am I feeling right now but it could
also be your light could be your car it
could be any other Internet connected
device and you can build that kind of
application on the neuro scale platform
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and we
are at the transformative technologies
conference it is super fun here and we
have an awesome guest joining us for
this episode I'm really excited we have
the Tim Mullen the dr. Tim Mullen
joining us hey man great to be here
thanks for coming out of the show yes
sir
I really appreciate it and the CEO of in
Theon and in Theon neuro tech anytime
anywhere and I will let's we'll unpack
how you're doing that and I will get
there I want to know who you are first
and how you got to where you're at how
did that even happen how did you feel
passionate about this well I was born
and then I ended up here so I wasn't
just born yesterday
but but I am a computational
neuroscientist by training my academic
training was first at Berkeley I was a
computer scientist back then my interest
was an artificial intelligence and I
wanted to really build computers that
could understand us that was my goal and
through that process I started to get
really interested in neuroscience
because it seemed to me like this is the
best example we have of a thinking thing
that can understand the dapped of the
world and so we can understand this
thing a little better maybe we can build
those thinking things a little better
and so I came through that process into
computational neuroscience which is what
my PhD was in at UC San Diego at the
Institute for neural computation and out
of that came in Theon the company that
I'm currently leading and and the
amazing team that that I have the
fortune of working with they're helping
deal with technology for everybody neuro
technology for everybody yes yes okay so
what does you you you you give this
really interesting thought is that
you're you like you like brain you like
a you CA you want AI to be better and a
good way to for that to be better
stunners
in the brain and this so yeah that's one
but it's kind of a means to an end you
know my my goal and our goal at in Theon
is to increase human potential what
humans are capable of I see artificial
intelligence as a extension of ourselves
or biology really if you think about it
the computing technologies create are
just an extension of ourselves and its
purpose I hope will be to increase our
capabilities as humans to get it allow
us to do things that we would not have
been able to do before
neuro technology serves a similar
purpose it's I think its ultimate
purpose is to enhance our capabilities
and take us to a new level and a new
dimension of what humans are capable of
and that an AI together can play in a
very synergistic way yeah a love
thinking about it as an extension of our
biology and then there is a there's this
element to it that I think the way the
way you speak about it super like calmly
and super I think it's because you
studied it so deeply I think maybe who
knows but the teach us a little bit
about the computation in the
neuroscience at the same time
neuroscience is a lot of data there's a
lot of data there's a lot of math
there's a lot of everything from brain
waves to how often a neuron is firing
what neurotransmitter is being sent
there's right yeah so the brain is very
very complicated as a neuroscientist I
can tell you confidently that I don't
understand how it works
so we're none of us understand really
how it works but we understand some
things about how it works
we have models of the brain the famous
statistician statisticians box and
Jenkins famously wrote all models are
wrong but some are useful and the
practical question is how wrong do they
have to be to not be useful yeah so I
like to think about it that way we are
fundamentally everything we think we
know about the brain is probably wrong
our models are probably wrong but some
of these models are actually very useful
and so some of the challenges that we
face in computational neural
science and neuro computation in general
is how do we take these signals as you
mentioned a lot of data that we can
record from the brain from the body also
from movement from the eyes and then
translate that into something that's
meaningful and useful that tells us
something about your state and there's a
lot of steps in that which involve
everything from taking those signals and
removing all the noise there's so much
noise in the signal that's not related
to those neurons firing your brain which
by the way we can't see from outside the
head but we can get kind of a noisy
chorus of activity and then we got to
filter that activity and extract out
from there the teeny little needle in
the haystack that is the signal that is
related to a particular state you're
interested in measuring like your
emotion or frustration or something like
that and that's essentially what we do
as computational neuroscientist as
machine learning enthusiasts and experts
to try to bring those things together
and do that decoding you have the
decoding and then as you're talking
about so much noise so little signal
yeah I'm thinking about Twitter more in
the Twittersphere there's a useful
comment so okay so so this is this is
really tough okay now there's so many
different methods to get the data that
then has to be decoded into these these
emotions yes yeah feeling now now the
way that we get the data right now is
mostly eg fMRI yeah so eg fMRI or two
tried-and-true methods for measuring
brain activity very different from
metals all yours comes from EEG far more
than fMRI okay and the main reason is
that an fMRI machine costs you know
anywhere from one to two million dollars
to purchase so I don't have one although
you know we have access to them as
scientists then we can use them for our
research but it's not something you're
going to just have an fMRI machine you
know lying around or Mr
my machine it's an MRI machine and we do
functional MRI but the other factor is
it's also very expensive to maintain
second or thirdly it is not a mobile
imaging technology you can't walk you're
lying prone you're inside a massive
magnet with a super conducting sphere
around it you know and it's it's not
something where you're gonna it's gonna
be useful in the workplace or in your
car or anything like that
EEG on the other hand even though it's
an older technology it's over it's over
100 years old it is yeah or well almost
100 years old 100 years everything this
is just 40 fifties
no 1930s actually and so you know it
goes all the way and actually you know
that it goes back further than that
that's when Hans Berger first really
popularized the notion of the
electroencephalograph yes and so and
some of the signals that he observed way
back then like the Alpha rhythm we're
still looking at today and still being
useful we're still understanding more
about that's how complicated the brain
is you know you can spend many many
decades looking at a signal and you're
still seeing new dimensions of how the
signal relates to behavior of the states
but but what's happened over that period
of time between then and now is the
technology is miniaturized miniaturized
miniaturized and the computing
capability has gone up and we now can
measure what what would have occupied an
entire room and had a lot of analog
circuits and a lot of you know
hardware now that can all be
miniaturized into a little chip that I
can pop in my ear and measure my brain
activity there for instance or put on my
forehead like in two racks on today that
was talking about their new device which
is just great for measuring brain
activity and all these kinds of wearable
EEG systems and so that's really the big
distinguishing factor between fMRI and
EEG in terms of its utility and it's
gonna get out there into the world and
get out their mobile contacts and be
able M be cheap be cost effective
accessible and scalable most of these
devices are like three hundred dollars
they can be any an EEG device can range
anywhere from fifty dollars to fifteen
thousand dollars and or more yeah it all
depends on the quality of the signal and
how many sensors and all of that relates
to how precisely you can image the brain
with EEG because you can actually image
the brain with EEG like you can with say
fMRI these are also the differences
between the two technologies you can see
into the brain but also the kind of
signal to noise characteristics in other
words how well can I extract that needle
in the haystack and so some RI makes it
easier it does make it easier to extract
certain kinds of things so if I want to
know where a signals coming for certain
so if I want to look at a specific area
of your brain and say is that area of
the brain activated when you're doing
task x with fMRI I can have good spatial
resolution and I can look at maybe about
one millimeter of your brain with EEG
it's a fuzzy view maybe the best I can
get is a centimeter to image that and
that's what's sophisticated signal
processing methods sophisticated
mathematics that let us try to look
deeply inside the brain and try to see
where the signals coming from fMRI is
looking at blood flow it's not really
blood flow it's a deoxygenated
hemoglobin and other stuffs but
basically what it's looking at is we can
think of it as looking at resource
consumption there's a good rather than
the electrical activity directly so in
neurons fire and they're active they can
more resources in this case yes and
there's a in oxygen so the oxygenated
hemoglobin and deoxygenated hemoglobin
ratio is different when there's more
activity in a particular part of the
brain that's called the bold signal but
it's an extraction of that but you know
to be honest and I'm not an expert with
that former I in the same way that I
know about EEG but I can say I think
pretty confidently that also there's a
lot we don't quite understand about
exactly what the mechanism is that is
driving that particular signal so then
out of now with this huge revolution of
just kind of it's just following kind of
Moore's law that we're having a
significant amount of computational
power for lower amounts of cost we're
able to wear it we're able to walk
around it that we're able to sleep with
it or a little amazing and so now you're
getting tons and tons and tons of data
and then so mote percentage most of your
data for me eg so a lot of our data is
from EEG but we also process data from
all kinds of other sensors so heart rate
monitor we do yeah i cracking devices if
you have a sensor on your muscle
recording your muscle act activity we
can make sense of that data to motion
capture accelerometers so we think of
this as a whole system's approach to
understanding the state of a person so
that we can optimize that and improve it
and so the brain is a seeing part of
that right but the body is actually the
brain is part of the body right we often
think of the brain and the body somehow
like they're two separate things but
it's all the body ok you know the brain
is a part of it
and you need to look at it from this
whole system's approach to really
understand what's going on you know R is
different algorithms for being able to
make signal from eg
then this from muscle or heart rate yeah
so there is there is some portion of the
mathematics and the and the signal
processing that translates across these
and there's others that don't
and so there's you know if I'm looking
at your movement activity the patterns
for all the patterns of movement active
and how I process that data is gonna be
different than if I'm trying to image
activity inside your brain but upstream
of all that let's say I have a signal
that is telling me how activated or how
much activity there was in a particular
part of your brain it's a time series
okay it's some squiggly thing and then
I've got some signal telling me how much
you moved or what your posture was at
every moment in the saint's in time two
of these signals at that point now it
becomes a machine learning problem to
say how are these related and how do
they predict your state and that part
can be very similar for all these
different domains the input can be
similar it's just patterns yeah so I can
take my favorite machine learning
approach it could be anything from you
know your sparse logistic regression to
your deep neural network to whatever you
want right and I can take these machine
learning techniques AI as we're now seem
to be all collectively calling it in
other words regression on a lot of data
anyways and I'm a big AI fan but I we're
taking this this stuff and now we're
applying that to these kinds of signals
and we can take we can take the
algorithms that Netflix the types of
algorithms Netflix uses to figure out
you know what type of movie you like we
can apply that to your bio signals to uh
you know those kinds of algorithms to
figure out how you're feeling you know
so at that point it doesn't relate so
much to the sensor the signal type
anymore although there is some
relationship but it's upstream that it
really matters yeah and that's a lot of
what we do at in theon is that we figure
out how to take that stream and turn it
into something useful and then we apply
machine learning on it and we give you
back something very simple like what is
the state of the person wearing the
sensor in real time
yeah through the cloud nice okay so as
long as the sensors are connected to the
cloud and then you have an account
within Theon then my data can real-time
be being processed by an Theon giving me
very close to real-time results of my
current physiology exactly so my goal is
to make it possible with as little as
five lines of code for you to access a
labs worth of state-of-the-art analytics
and signal processing to obtain a
meaningful state like for instance
what's your frustration state or what's
your emotional state or your attentional
state and to be able to integrate then
that signal in real time into any
internet-connected device or application
so I could have a little wearable on my
wrist and a sensor on my head or some
day in my brain if as we get to the
point when you talk about implants if
you want later but I could have that
little wearable that has almost no
computational capability at all tapping
into almost limitless computational
capability in the Wow yeah and telling
me in real time what that state is and
that's you know that's the power of its
computation it's a sensor going to cloud
the cloud coming back to a device that
allows me to act meaningfully on that
state or my car for ins another good
example is that my car could be asking
our cloud service which is called neuro
scale asking neuro scale
what's the drivers mind-wandering state
right now is the driver focused or is
the driver starting to drift away yeah
it's just asking you know once a second
or ten times a second what's that state
if I'm wearing a sensor sending that
data up then we can do all the
sophisticated computation and my car can
now be aware of my state and then it can
act proactively to increase safety but
maybe taking over if it knows that I'm
not capable of stopping in time if
something happens it can basically um
amp up its own automated AI system
division
hey I got to take the wheel for a bit
here because you know Tim is not in a
good state yeah and then mmm this is
also very helpful for emotion regulation
it could be it could where where is it
most helpful right now so there's a
whole emerging space of you know what
used to be called neurofeedback but now
it's kind of you know in the broader
space of neuromodulation closed-loop
neuromodulation and the basic principle
is that the brain is a plastic system
which means that it is adaptable it's
changing constantly based on inputs and
internal goals and there's a reward
system in the brain that's constantly
trying to shift and change how different
areas the brain wire up and talk to each
other to optimize a desired outcome and
that's evolutionarily what the brain is
essentially designed to do or as evolved
to do and so if you can construct a
system that can measure activity from a
part of the brain let's say it's an area
of the brain involved in you know that
might be related to the mood and I can
record activity from that Erin let's say
increasing activity in that area of the
brain is shown scientifically to
increase my sense of well-being or my
mood now if I can measure that that
signal related to activity in that area
and then feed that back and so maybe
let's put it into a game where the only
way I win the game is by increasing
activity in that part of the brain the
brain will learn to increase activity in
that part of the brain and we believe if
you design this closed-loop system in
the right way you can get that to be a
permanent effect or at least a
long-lasting effect
good evening because Elliot has been
working on this for a long time but
neuro therapeutic games right exactly
exactly and so Achille is trying to do
that with behavior right yes but it can
also extend into the neuro space where
at some point you're now directly
reading from the brain and then you're
adapting that circuit to improve
performance or achieve a desired outcome
yeah
another possibility is neuro stimulation
so you could also stimulate the brain
while yeah after a while you're
measuring it to try to touch
those circuits and the as you're saying
that I'm thinking about the absolutely
incredible benefits I'm also thinking
about what we've seen in the last 10
years with addiction to the social media
totally yeah yeah I mean we have to be
very proactive in thinking about the
future use cases of these technologies
and you know we shouldn't revert to
Luddite ism which is to say let's ban
the technology but we have to also not
throw ourselves headlong and
thoughtlessly into you know those
domains without really thinking okay
what are we doing why are we building
this are we building the right thing how
are we using it and that's a social
discourse you know a societal discourse
and it's it's a global discourse that
has to be carried out yes and it is
happening but it is very important of
course yes yes okay so let's talk about
the the data that's coming in and making
sense of the day that's coming in and
what is the but as much as we can talk
about it because I know at some point
you're going way over my head with
actual computational neuroscience
analysis but so okay you're getting
you're getting this information that's
coming in from let's say an EEG and that
you are your I mean it depends on where
the EEG is located on the person's head
in the first place and then and then it
depends on how frequently they're
sending you to read out of information
right and then right yeah how many how
many electrodes there are all factors
absolutely and how well we can decode a
state so so that you know the well there
wasn't exactly a question there but the
answer if I was to pose an answer to the
state of quest on like your answer yes
it would be that that you're pointing
out one of the big challenges of neuro
technology which is that the design of
the sensors and the hardware and where
you put it and how you measure that
signal and then what you do with it all
allow us to achieve different levels of
performance and
brain activity and when you're trying to
say build a device that addresses a
particular you know problem and you need
to know where do I put that sensor and
how many sensors do I need and what type
of algorithm do I use to do the decoding
all of that can be a massive research
project that's very difficult to to
undertake and can take you months or
longer years sometimes and a lot of
expertise and resources now at in Theon
we've been working in this space for a
long time our team so we have a pretty
good understanding of where those what
kinds of sensors will be useful for
decoding a certain kind of state and
where you should put those kinds of
sensors and part of what we're doing by
interfacing with many different sensor
types and then having many different
types of pipelines and algorithms you
can apply to those and allowing you to
quickly iterate by taking a sensor off
the market and plugging it into this
algorithm and testing it and within a
week being able to say oh hey did that
work for me that that achieved the
outcome I wanted for my product or my
device you know be able to measure that
impact you can very quickly iterate
through that space to find what the
right combination is of device and and
algorithm or pipeline for your specific
application and so that's one of the
things that we're helping to accelerate
dreaming models we're training models on
yeah we are training we are training
models we have model with training
models with lots of different kinds of
data and trying to understand how that
data specifically relates to a state of
interest like for instance let's say if
we're just talking about emotion you
know one of those questions might be do
I need four sensors do I need 20 sensors
do I need 64 sweaters and where do I put
those right some of these are unanswered
questions do you have enough we're
answering some of those questions well
there again it depends on the type of
application so within a motion yeah yeah
so I can tell you for instance if you
have one sense or two sensors you're not
going to get a reliable while two
sensors the minimum you're not going to
get a rely
we'll measure if you have 64 sensors we
can decode your emotional state in
certain context with you know about 76%
accuracy or so in certain contexts and
then in between there's a gradient
alright and so and that gradient is part
of what we help when we work with
companies more closely we help them
understand ok for this sensor this type
of algorithm or pipeline that we have is
going to be useful for you but as our
ecosystem continues to grow we think we
can automate all of this stuff where you
say okay I have a sensor of this type
well we know that that sensor of that
type typically with this pipeline will
produce a good result for this
particular application like let's say
for a motion and then we can say ok well
the sensor that you have is not going to
be useful for decoding emotion you need
at least this many sensors in this
location
and with this pipeline of this algorithm
we can now reliably decode that
emotional state that comes out of having
access to more and more data yeah and
what does it look like when you partner
with neuro tech companies and then their
their hardware is getting the data and
then how does that how does that work so
the way that our platform works is that
you can kind of think of it as like I
don't know if you're familiar with
nuance they you know dragons soft
naturally speaking became nuance but
basically as a speech decoding company
that and you know through the 90s and
into the aughts became a platform in the
cloud where you basically use their API
and you send it waveforms of your speech
waveforms and it run they run algorithms
that they've now trained on tons of data
and they provide back to you what the
decoded you know speech is the text
right ok and you basically pay for the
use of that our model is similar but for
biosensors so you send it biosensor day
if you're a company and you want to work
with us you don't even have to partner
with us you could just use our API yes
you literally just connect your sensor
to our API send us data stream us data
choose what kind of state you want
decoded and not all state decoding is
possible with all types of sensors and
Jim you have the right type of sensor
then you can apply the appropriate
pipeline and you get back again through
the API
the interpreted state so if I want to
measure let's say again something like
let's this pick attention your
attentional state if we have an
attention pipeline there on the cloud
then you get a sensor you plug it in you
say I want to measure the person's
attention once per second and you simply
with a few lines of code in your app you
just ask the server
what's the attention state of the person
right now that's it and you just get
that back as a number all the rest of
the machinery all happens on our end and
you don't you know you don't need to do
anything more than just send data
through that API as a developer you can
make the link it's in Theon and then the
consumer makes the decision that went to
actually make the calls for the so the
developer would build let's say that
you're a developer building a app to
measure attention right you would build
an app for your consumer and your
consumer and you as the developer you as
the developer for a company you know
have your consumer provider relationship
the consumer never talks to us yeah
consumer goes there you go yes the
consumer pink pull paint queries the
developer and the yeah the assumer
basically just where's the device right
they use the app as far as they know
they're using an app from let's call
them you know sugar charge and because
we'll never know because soon we'll
never know that it's in Theon behind the
scenes
powering it so it's kind of like like
Amazon Web Services yeah exactly
90% of the time your if you anything on
the cloud or not 90% but you know high
forty percent of the time probably
you're using Amazon Web Services you
might be using Azure you might be using
Google cloud either way you know that
you're using this app but behind the
scenes all the heavy lifting in terms of
the
the not necessary the computation but
the computing infrastructure is being
done there for us it's all the
intelligence of the decoding and making
sense of those signals that's all done
by us behind the scenes yeah yeah I want
it I still want to be walked through if
possible possible on your end what it
would be like to be wearing one of these
using a service and I am measuring my
emotional state of my attention state we
were saying attention state so if I'm
measuring my attention state and I want
a pain is this this is probably a pretty
normal request would be to get a ping
when my mind is wandered for like five
or ten minutes or something when I'm
trying to focus or five seconds even
right yeah when I'm trying to focus and
so then what I'm wearing probably a full
cap or something close I'm wearing a lot
of electrodes maybe but not necessarily
so certain things are measurable with
increasingly more miniaturized devices
so for instance measuring a rough analog
of someone's attention is possible with
you know as little as you know one or
two sensors because you're only on like
because the activity well it's where the
where it's placed is one aspect of it
but also because the type of signal
that's related to attention is a it's a
pretty large signal that's pretty well
measurable through EEG and of course I
have to be I have to sort of qualify
that by saying that we don't have a
definition of attention that we're all
agreeing on here so I'm using attention
very loosely here there are forms of
attention like spatial attention that I
you know like are you attending to that
point in space or that point that I'm
not going to be able to measure with
that one sensor but in terms of like am
i cognitively focused or not that's
something that you can measure using a
pretty low number of sensors if you deal
with the noise appropriately to some
degree of reliability that is useful and
and so you don't necessarily need a
large number of sensors to get something
useful out and even better if you can
probe the brain like I can have you do a
five minute task
probing the brain measuring the response
of the brain yes in that task I can
extract even more information with an
even lower channel count or lower
dimensional we call it sensor you know a
lower number of sensors and still get a
highly meaningful result out nice and
then that makes sense and then if you
also have the task be a measurement of
maybe their baseline and then you can
then work with the company to do an
activity that's right the baseline so
that's one possibility is you can have
an intervention or a boost or something
and that boost could be you know
stimulating your brain doing an activity
meditating if you're trying to say
reduce your stress one of many different
kinds of interventions but the key is
you want to then measure what the effect
of the intervention was so let's say I'm
trying to do something here where my
goal is to improve your attention okay
and while you're focused on pick your
type of task and I do that by
stimulating a particular part of the
prefrontal cortex okay so you put on a
device you stimulate the brain and then
you do a quick five-minute task and now
I measure the response of your brain in
that task now I want to know when I
stimulated your brain did I improve the
response in your brain I improve it I
change brain activity in a way that
indicates that I'm improving brain
function and then if I didn't then I
want to modify my stimulator to Target
it in a different way to create the
desired effect that actually has an
impact on the brain and so that cycle of
measuring predicting and intervening
changing the state and then measuring
the effect of the intervention that
whole cycle that's something that that
we help to make very well I wouldn't say
very easy but much easier to do than if
you were to try to build that whole
analysis pipeline and and and framework
for both the prediction and the
assessment oh yeah yeah so now companies
can come in with just an intention to
have activities and then use your
infrastructure to process the data and
exactly like to figure out
that activity have an effect on the
brain and these particular ways that
were interested in looking at it through
their to change activity in parts of the
brain that are related to attention
let's say yes no yes good and that
person we have the right intervention
you know no then let's try a different
intervention yep the key is being able
to iterate rapidly in that space so the
key to all innovation is failing many
times we forget that failure is the path
to success and we have to fail early and
fail quick and in order to do that we
need to not expend a ton of resources on
a problem only to find that it was the
wrong question we are asking right and
how many of us have all like embarked on
a great ambitious project and dedicated
a year of our lives or months or weeks
only to find there's nothing there you
know as scientists we encounter that all
the time but I think all of us in some
sense has encountered that in every
creative project we do any product
you're building you think you have the
right market fit well you want to find
out like really early is my is my
product gonna have the desired effect
you know that I want as early as
possible so that you can iterate and
iterate and iterate until you go out
with your product and hit the market so
again that's an area that we feel you
know is really important it's one that
we were really committed to helping
shorten that that cost and time to do
all of that signal analysis and
processing so you can get an answer your
question really quickly you know is my
device having the impact I want am i
measuring something useful you know in
in neuroscience if you make that mistake
it's it's a comp it's a really
complicated place to make that can be
because it's hard to see like where was
my you know where was the mistake and
that that's a lot of time that you were
taking on that
luckily so then yeah yeah and then I
want to ask this question as well it's
where within your data or your machine
learning algorithms where is the biggest
hole in the data set for now like
where's the least amount of data about
the brain and where is the the most
amount of data suppose you can share
it's a good question
so from non-invasive sensors like EEG we
have quite a lot of actually laboratory
grade data data collected from people
sitting down in an environment where
you're having them do a particular task
and you've constrained it and isolated
them so we know a lot about for instance
how the visual system processes targets
like when you are looking for something
like a Where's Waldo and you find Waldo
like we can that we can predict we can
detect when your brain finds Waldo as
fast as your brain is actually
consciously finding Waldo though you
know like as its as the neural actually
there's there's a signature of that even
if you're not consciously aware of
having found Waldo you know it happens
fast and even before the conscious -
we're just so we can decode that very
very 400 milliseconds crazy 250 or so
that's so nuts that that when I as I
find Waldo you see that I found Waldo
right and then I become aware right it's
so interesting or another example is
making errors when you're making
mistakes right let's say I'm you're
you're doing a task a simple task where
you have to you know press a left button
or right button at a particular point in
time yeah this is an interesting it's a
simple type of task although like a
flanker task it means a little more
complicated that but essentially it
comes down to making a choice between
two buttons whoever else press the
launch button or the not launch buttons
or whatever so when you press the wrong
button some percentage of the time you
will become consciously aware of having
made that mistake but well before that
actually happens or even if you don't
become consciously aware the brain knows
that you
the wrong button and when it knows it
generates a signal that is sort of a
signal to the rest of the brain like a
reinforcement learning signal saying we
think at least saying hey whatever you
did there was the wrong thing okay so
don't do it again
now that signal we can measure faster
than you can correct your mistake yeah
which means that if you're Auto typing
and you you know fat-finger the button
or whatever you know which I do all the
time me too you know then in theory with
one of these sensors actually in
practice you could auto correct that
mistake and so that's an that's an
example of an area where we have a lot
of knowledge a lot of data around these
kinds of you know of paradigms and of
systems and we can do pretty good and be
at decode in those kinds of states areas
where it's where we need a lot more data
are multifold but at least in a few key
areas one is getting data outside the
lab so when I sit you down in a room and
I probe your brain I'm seeing I'm seeing
your brain in in that context this is
not your brain when you're out with your
friends when you're at home when you're
driving in your car right exercising the
brain is adaptive having a Eureka moment
like a genius moment yeah right and so
the context of your environment changes
your brain and how your brain behaves
and even the signatures in your brain
that might indicate that you found Waldo
will be different than the signature
that indicate you found the dress that
you are looking for in the shopping you
know while you're walking through Macy's
or the or that you you know that you
spotted your friend across the room
right although there will be some
similarities there's differences so we
need more and more data out there in the
wild I call it or we call it you know
the wild of the world yeah which is not
the lab not the lab so one of the key
things is making the world the
laboratory where you put biosensors on
people and they can just go out about
their daily lives and we record data and
try to understand how their brain is
relating to the things they're looking
at and engaging with and see
and then building machine learning
models that ultimately can make sense of
that kind of data so that's another
challenge this is why I want to put the
e G's on the heads of six artists that
go with you Sakai did though oh yes
exactly review the overview yeah that
would be fantastic
it'd be great to you know work we're
collaborating with with the human
spaceflight laboratory right now in
North Dakota hopefully trying to help
build some sensing technology that could
help with long duration deep-space
exploration for NASA getting us to
hopefully extend the duration of these
missions to Mars and the moon and stuff
and I'm a huge proponent of neuro tech
in space and how important it is that we
have to also measure how the brain is
changing when you're up there in space
yeah well you're talking about something
a little different which is what's the
experience that the person's feeling the
artist will convey that yeah what if you
know what if we could what if we could
see inside their minds oh now we're not
there yet
you won't give you a window that is
crystal clear into that person's mind
no never gonna happen with EEG but we
might be able to see something cool from
that and who knows maybe decades from
now that data that's collected will find
the needle in the haystack that we can't
find now you know so what's going on
with all of the giants the kernel and
the neural link there seems to be a
there's a lot of it a I safety and
security researchers and but
geopolitical pressures are like be the
first ones collect all the data make the
biggest moves don't worry so much about
ethical considerations which is making
it difficult to have those hard
conversations yeah so the future of
neuro technology I think is is a story
of exponential growth that we are at the
very beginning of supervening right ok
so it's important first to understand
that because an exponential trend starts
out looking very flat yes
yeah and even in the beginning of it it
looks linear yes but the thing about
exponential trends is they change very
very quickly and we're right now
entering into that that upswing and it's
been happening for a few decades on the
other hand the fact that we can see what
the trend might looks like means that we
often have a tendency to sort of maybe
prognosticate in a way that where we
think oh it's going to be 10 years and
we're all going to be walking around
with implants in our brains and we're
all going to have the ability to
communicate through telepathy you know
in 15 years and you know and and so the
we have to be a little bit conservative
when we think about where the technology
is and also how quickly it can be
adopted out there in the world
so what kernel and neural Inc are doing
is they're working primarily in the
space of invasive technology implants
which ideally would not require a
surgery ideally there are different ways
of recording signals inside the brain
now all through for instance putting up
your vein you can snake up a little very
very thin wire and record activity
inside your brain doing all the stent
Road Road but actually because it's like
a stent right that's used with you know
cardiovascular or another technology
that's made its rounds it's called
neural dust by Michael maharba niz and
Jose Carmen a UC Berkeley very cool
technology MEMS well really this isn't
quite yet MEMS but you know very small
devices of course uses MEMS technology
but very small devices that can record
brain activity and be wirelessly power -
power through ultrasound which is pretty
cool I mean can even potentially
stimulate so you can record and
stimulate from these little teeny little
sensor stimulators that can be sprinkled
if you will throughout the brain or
across the the brain the surface of the
brain that technology is is still also
in its infancy and
they needed it needs to be miniaturized
significantly from where it is to be
that really truly dust like where is
your just it's invisible stuff sprinkled
throughout your brain but someday that
kind of technology might be the future
of neural interfaces and that future may
not maybe very well very well in our
lifetimes yeah we will you may have this
in your head in your lifetime that is a
possibility yeah and you know when that
happens is still the unknown so that's
an area those kinds of things or the
kinds of things that like say kernel and
neural ink are looking at and and other
things in that space others are looking
like merely Jepson with open water he's
looking at you know optical tomographic
imaging approaches you know using light
basically to image the brain and so
that's a potentially non-invasive way to
to image the brain at higher resolutions
and see what's going on in there
there's again needs to still need to see
how that will be proven out especially
when you try to make a consumer device
out of it and so it's one thing to do in
a lab with a million dollar device and
another thing to make it something
that's a little band-aid but that's the
goal of say open water and there's
others who are also pioneering in this
space it's a very exciting and fertile
ground in which a lot of activity is
happening but it's still early days yeah
we we add in Theon see many of these
technologies as the future of sensing
and we are laying the groundwork in our
platform for these technologies we
actually just finished out a larger
project to integrate a large number of
signal processing algorithms for
processing implant data so now we can
process over 15 different implantable
file types and pull out spikes and
spikes are little discharges of a neuron
you know so we can process that kind of
data too so you know we thinking in 20
years when those devices hit the market
we'll be ready to decode the activity
from those sensors - yeah the cloud and
connect your brain directly
to to whatever device or application you
wish to connect it to decoding knurled
us decoding neural does slow and that's
gonna require a lot of heavy lifting and
processing because the amount of data
you're gonna be getting if you think
it's a lot from EEG many many orders of
magnitude larger when you're recording
from implants yeah both in terms of the
you know the the how frequently you're
sampling data as well as how many
sensors you have you know and how many
different neurons you're recording from
I mean there's you know 100 billion of
them in there almost that's a lot that's
a lot but now where does one take indy
on next what does what are you guys up
to next time how many people USF right
now we're a pretty small team we've
always been on on the right now and you
know the order of about 10 people yeah
full-time and then but we hope to be
growing a lot soon yeah we're doing some
exciting things that all hope to be
announcing soon but our focus right now
is on this platform to empower and
enable the community of transformative
technology folks of people wanting to do
more with their bio sensor data to
really empower them to to to find those
killer apps and to get to that point
very quickly where they can have a
useful and impactful neuro technology
application that really has meaning and
we want to help you do all the heavy
lifting through our platform all that
decoding and sensing and so our future
for in Theon is very much into growing
this ecosystem growing this platform I
just actually today gave a little
preview of our new neuro scale insights
a service that will be fully launching
in a couple months but we're now
accepting early previews into and this
is a whole system for being able to just
record data upload that data apply a
pipeline and get back all your processed
results statistical models BCI miles and
also interactive reports that are a
graphical that show you you can interact
with them and shows you all your data
features it shows you you know a lot of
it rich information about what was in
your data what's the quality of your
data
what are your neural signals look like
what is your statistical model look like
you know all through this interactive
report alright and so but the cool thing
is that you can do this if I was
collecting data from you right now and I
wanted to know did the data set I just
got was it was a good quality did I get
the effect I wanted from you am I seeing
that thing in the brain I'm looking for
I can know literally while you're still
sitting there within like five ten
minutes of you having recorded that data
I can have what would take your research
associate you know months to code up all
the algorithms and then take the data
and run this typical mob and make the
figures all that stuff in your
fingertips while you're still sitting
there and then I could say oh maybe I
need to change my experiment hey let me
get another hour with you you know but
also this kind of application for
insights can be really exciting and
useful I think for for the for
product-focused applications for
instance one example is if I'm if I'm I
have a company that tries to optimize
say human performance you know I'm
trying to optimize human performance I
want to know did my intervention the my
brain stimulation or whatever it is that
I'm applying did I get the effect I
wanted well our reporting system can
tell you that very very quickly from a
person you know did that change in the
brain that I was looking for happened
when I stimulated the brain or when I
did that thing and furthermore it can be
useful for you to have your own kind of
quantified self report that says oh
here's how my brain activities changed
over time so all these applications of
this this new service that we're
launching I love that synthesis just a
landing page that just makes me feel
like I am deeply in tune and in touch
with what exists up here yeah that's a
big big part of it you know absolutely
that we're properly crunching everything
yeah so interesting now oh I want to ask
you this question this is probably good
one ask you is consciousness localized
in the body
I'd say that's a a that is a big
question so I don't know and I don't
think anybody knows but there's a lot of
theories about where consciousness
arises from some have argued that there
is places like the colostrum people it
was a popular place you know that people
thought maybe this is the nexus where
maybe some kind of interesting
integration happens which is necessary
for consciousness you know Descartes
thought it was the you know the pineal
gland the realities we don't know where
the seed of consciousness is is if there
even is a single seat of consciousness
my personal theory is that the one that
I subscribe to is that consciousness
doesn't arise in any one place it is a
distributed phenomenon it arises through
the interaction of many different
subsystems of the brain communicating
with each other and modeling each other
the brain modeling itself it's like
indras net you know about indras net the
mirrors that are all infinitely
reflecting themselves the brain in some
sense is when you look into the
architecture of the brain it has some of
these kinds of properties where every
part of the brain connected to many
other parts of the brain is sort of
creating its own model of what it thinks
that part of the brain's input is and
what it thinks that part of the brain is
doing so it's kind of like the auditory
cortex having a version in its own
version of what it thinks the visual
cortex is from the auditory cortex
detective and vice versa okay now out of
this nexus may arise conscious
experience the the self-awareness that
we that we experience and yeah that
requires certain areas there are
necessary areas of the brain for us to
be conscious that if you remove those
parts of the brain you are not conscious
but it you know that doesn't mean that
those are the seats of consciousness
right and so I think the the big
question for for a consciousness
research both up until now and in for
the next hundred years is to try to look
deeper and deeper into the brain and
find those areas of the brain they're
not only the
no necessary but also sufficient or both
sufficient and necessary for
consciousness and then try to from that
gain a clearer theory of where
consciousness truly arises what about
outside of the vehicle as a soul that's
that's a very interesting not then then
we we border on the metaphysical at some
point potentially and I think that is
also an area where one must depart from
you know from science because science is
not a is only a tool for being able to
explain things using observation and so
the soul I cannot observe it and I
cannot use scientific methods to test
for its existence for now for now unless
you find a way to observe this also who
knows I don't know but I'd I personally
believe that where we should focus our
attention scientifically is on the
questions that we can falsify ibly
develop a falsifiable hypothesis around
in other words i can develop i posit
that i can test the truth or falsity yes
because i have the tools to do it yes
and if we focus our attention
scientifically there then we'll make a
lot of progress the other areas are
areas that we absolutely should continue
to explore and discuss and debate so for
instance you know the question of
where's the soul is there a soul that
where does it reside that's a question
that that absolutely is deserving of
discussion and discourse but science
isn't really the right tool i think yet
to answer that particular question
because we don't have the observational
tools that would allow us I think to
gain that particular insight but that
said you raised actually what you said
though that was interesting as is this
notion make consciousness live outside
the body or outside the brain and I want
to posit this other idea that
consciousness does not actually exist in
your brain solely consciousness is a
distributed phenomenon that also exists
in the minds of others yes in the
environment around us and we actually
offload our consciousness and cognition
constantly into the devices that we
interact with and into other people by
interacting with them you have a memory
of me
instance or memory of me that
interaction between us means that it to
some extent the information that is part
of my conscious self-awareness is also
in to some extent imputed into your
system right so and then comes and feeds
back into me when we interact that's so
elective yeah and so there's these
interesting patterns of loops inside my
brain I have these areas of the brain
talking to each other you know and out
of that emergence conscious but then
we're all networked together as a
society as well you know through our
interactions with each other and also
with the world around us that we
interact with and some of our
consciousness and cognition may actually
reside there to some extent I don't
really mean this metaphysically although
it could be if you're a property dualist
you may actually think that
consciousness is in everything you know
but I I mean there's more in in a in a
kind of complex systems way yeah that
that consciousness may extend outside
ourselves so to understand consciousness
we need to not just understand the brain
but we need to understand the context in
which somebody's acting when you
understand the relationships with the
people around them they interact with
devices and things exactly yeah because
then that's what actually ends up
sculpting their architecture yeah
exactly and they're thinking yeah this
is so awesome and so interestingly deep
about the brain and I'm just I've I'm
really happy to know someone that's
taking the computational neuroscience
approach someone that's building out the
like they wso of neural processing and
now that's fascinating like I love that
thank you yeah well we just want to help
grow the field and you know we all have
these I think visions of what neuro
technology can do and our goal is to
help you realize yours basically we want
to make it possible for your vision of
what neuro technology can do for
Humanity possible yeah and to get there
as fast as possible and as with with as
reliable and scientifically validated an
approach as possible because that's key
to you know
do it the right way start with good
tools yes yes um this has been a huge
pleasure thank you thank you yeah yeah
real pleasure to be here I'm looking I'm
looking forward to some some of your
comments about this episode because this
has been thanks for tuning in this has
been such a it's a totally again it's
it's a it's a it's a computational
neuroscience market-place toolset
building out the future of what we need
to actually figure out what's going on
in here and in in a software side of
things yeah and that's and that's always
refreshing to hear about things that
like can really scale and can really
have people from around the world
sending in data learning about different
cultures and learning about different
emotions and feelings there's so much to
unpack and it's just part one you know
there's so much more left we got to get
you into into the brain mind ecosystem
there's a lot of really fun ecosystems
do you know Vivian being over at
Berkeley I know of and we've been
connected but we have not we have not
spent time yeah I she's the one that
taught me like four years ago she taught
me about maximizing human potential and
yeah and she got me hooked
and how many opportunities for for that
for for taking us from where we are now
to the next level you know there's if
you know if there's a civilizations have
potentially scales you know 10 10 levels
for you know for civilization we're on
level zero I want to see us at level one
who's that gonna look like just a five
and eight year olds running around right
now earth because we don't have the
proper stewardship you know yet we're
gonna develop that out well it's
important to build things like
stewardship into our our technological
growth system being yes and being
conscious about that as we're developing
the technology being aware of what its
implications are and and and building in
principles of stewardship into the into
the technological growth process so that
the technology is inherently for good
you know and that we the Z that will it
will grow into a beautiful tree that
will
we'll be good for everybody yeah yes
yeah everyone please go check out the
link in the bio and also check out check
out check out what you you know what
what you with what you've learned go and
build go and manifest your dreams into
the world go and execute and much love
everyone we will see you soon
[Music]